yeah good morning oh yeah my voice is
going welcome to son diary it is the
wrap-up of my week kind of a day in the
life blog type of thing where you get to
see everything that I've done all week
we're here at Cosmo calm there's a me
yeah we're doing it look you can tell
it's Cosmo flowers and the fur rug god
dammit could you be any more Cosmo right
now okay back in a hotel room and right
now I'm about to get started doing a
reddit AMA ask me anything I've never
done one of these before and I try and
stay away from rip it itches read it
does not agree with me hmm
I remember posting a few things I read
it in the past and they just got yeah
they got read it is they got just like
fist in the butthole look at New York
City did you know that they renovated
New York City so it's just like one big
white light will you please explain to
me what you're about to eat will you
please explain to me what you find so
funny coconut for New York City and you
just call down to room service for a
decent sized knife so you could open up
a coconut they didn't laugh they're like
we got juicer yeah answer Dean's
so yeah this is a lunch of champions can
smoked oysters
I just got a gift sent up to my hotel
room from my editor it's a whole bucket
of Red Bull yeah and it says to keep you
going Lauren she knows that this is
gonna be a crazy couple of weeks I will
be using these this is the bucket I can
get behind
Oh going upstairs for in the first
behind me and this is as you ever
wondered what the backstage of a
bookstore looks like it looks like this
so here's the book yeah
they're awful yes no the real stars look
at this
oh look there's my mom putting makeup on
yeah we're in Ridgewood New Jersey we're
in Jersey yay for another book signing
my stepdads over there holding flowers
just like a real support system my mom -
my mom is part-time mom full-time makeup
artist and we are about to go to this
book signing excited very excited okay I
just had her film some stuff for her no
filter show show she's like on right now
let's go hey doing you look like a
Beatle right now life sucks
very special place Oh a to the
mothership mothership mothership Google
yay this is the calm before the storm of
the livestream
yeah you are look beautiful there's a
nice cascading red light on all of you
look up you're all in a panic room
together
boss hello we have made it to Boston
look at this very New England style
groom like clam chowder came to life as
traditional style furniture it's a
really rainy gray day here in Boston I'm
gonna do some interviews over the phone
Tim my brother is coming to visit and I
think he might come to the signing
tonight which is gonna happen after
these interviews I'm gonna shower the
scum off my person
even the police sirens in Boston sound
like they have sticks up their asses
Boston your gray we made it to the book
signing event in Boston look who showed
up - yeah don't worry she didn't ask me
to come I just walked in and found him
waiting don't worry his hair hasn't
changed color because the light is
cascading on him it's change color
because he actively changed its color
yeah speaking of chemicals and food
products signing some books before we go
into the actual signing next just some
you know literature some this is a
really good read the end gets a little
weird but highly recommend
apparently our hotel we've learned has a
dog as a mascot that they gave us a gift
to all the guests so guests can walk it
or pet it and we found the dog house
there's the duck and the breed is
umbrella but no there's actually an
umbrella heck no yeah but apparently
there's two dogs that just kind of
wander around that people are allowed to
to just exist around we're gonna find
them look oh my gosh
Hotel dogs hot dogs hot dogs this is the
greatest Hotel of all time
but the faster new editor Chicago
for the first no feel to show come on
three hours of sleep right now
it's a beautiful day
Wow boobs aren't gonna wash themselves
so this is the theater yay everyone
showed up great show haha hey good
morning guys
it is the morning after our first in the
filter show in Chicago that is the back
of my person back there you can tell
it's the morning after I firstly tell to
show my voice excuse me already going
I'm going to the gym really quick before
I have to leave and do a couple
interviews that had two radio interviews
this morning with this voice one of the
radio hosts instantly commented on it
being very sexy that's how I know we're
not right for each other and then
tonight there's a book signing in
Naperville Illinois which I guess is a
suburb outside of Chicago very exciting
here's hoping that it's a books I think
I'm going to and not piss away for my
team of professionals to kidnap me in
Illinois listen isn't that Illinois just
the pure unadulterated glamour hello
okay so I made to the bookstore that is
my signing here outside of Chicago and
I'm in the bathroom not obviously not
the bookstore and they have a really
great sign here in the bathroom yes but
this is their freshman please use it
when applicable noses everywhere thank
you
I live here now
ha we're here for our Brooklyn show at
the bathhouse look it's so crowded with
people beautiful just high art and
fashion and design very exciting this is
perfect for my bit which is a medieval
times joust trade before no filter Bob
Brooklyn ok guys
whatever here
Oh what's going on this has been
happening for a very long time I was
reading though mm-hmm that's exactly
what you were doing I want to know what
Bill Cosby husband do I didn't know that
he's it's on us but there you go there
was my week there's still a lot more
stuff to come with the rest of the book
tour and the rest of the note filter
shows that we're doing we're coming for
you Minneapolis and Denver and today
we're doing a show in Manhattan and then
uh you can also get my book that this
whole thing is happening for at Great
Escape book.com and I want to remind you
that if you go to hey you aside at the
scene calm you can watch the full
episodes of may Mirandized travel show
that we did this summer it's so it's
really just a stupid time and I hope
that you go over and check them up I
don't know
I'm really really excited because where
is it ah I got a package in New York and
I haven't think I know what it is
it's mock-ups of the new sweatshirts
that I'm selling it's great sweatshirts
and say I don't know look cute oh my
gosh I love it oh my gosh can you see in
this light
look oh if someone comes up to you and
they're like hey how do I get to Times
Square BAM I just do you think that I
have a bola whoa just to present to
present if you guys want to go and get
these they're really they're available
for a limited time and represent calm
slush its grace - since it's my second
campaign with them and a bunch of you
have already pre-ordered so make sure
that you pre-order yours because they're
limited edition and they're like they're
long enough for my long arms there's
some good choreography